[Musique]
toi
le pilote demande des gens qui sont
en fait et celui qui a de l'argent accueille
de très grande classe car les financements sont
chers dans ce domaine je sais qu'on
peut effectivement se permettre des tas d'argent ou
des cours de danse pour je pense que c'est en fait
très visuel nous présenter nos gens
ici parce que c'est en fait les aider à
savoir que cela peut aussi être fait par
eux-mêmes
[Musique]
mon rêve est de faire en sorte que les enfants du
monde entier puissent partager le même
esprit que ceux qui s'intéressent à
vain
je veux qu'ils puissent exprimer leurs
sentiments pour danser et peut-être un jour aimer
la danse - chansu un peu mieux devrait les
encadrer et leur apprendre à danser
[Musique]
vous